this is one of the strangest new  products I've seen in a long time this  is a hip dot icon baked eye pigment  Shadow I definitely got a better  application and color payoff with my  finger but still the formula was dry and  I was tugging at my eyelid which I did  not like I finally got my hands on this  4-3 beauty honey pot lip care kit the  scrub is like a regular sugar scrub it  made my lips feel really soft this lip  mask felt incredible it's thick and  smooth and really hydrating and it  tastes sweet which I liked Hollow Taco  polishes have been super popular since  they were released but I've actually  never tried them I obviously had to test  out some holographic polishes both of  these also applied really well and had  amazing color payoff